a historic referendum in Ireland today
could relax that country's strict
anti-abortion laws Jonathan Vigliotti is
in Dublin where Irish citizens from all
over the world have arrived to vote
Jonathan good morning good morning and
we've been watching people filing in all
morning long to cast their vote this is
expected to be an incredibly tight vote
we'll learn the results tomorrow morning
ultimately those I've spoken with say
this is a referendum on the future
direction of the nation for a country so
closely entwined with the Catholic
Church months of polarizing protests
have signaled a seismic cultural shift
voters today will select yes or no to
repeal Ireland's 8th amendment which
bans all abortions except when a
mother's life is at risk the law was
created in 1983 supported by those who
feared Ireland having its own roe v wade
moment since the 1973 ruling legalized
abortion in America Ireland has been
considered a pro-life beacon it's a
torch genomic brain wants to carry for
unborn children with disabilities grace
was born pink and screaming her
three-year-old daughter Grace has Down
syndrome
it wasn't my rice determinates to decide
when to terminate her life but
pro-choice campaigners like Ivana bachik
say the current law ultimately hurts
women just as caused this immense trauma
has blocked any reform of abortion law
and of course it hasn't stopped Irish
women having abortion in 2016 over 3,000
women from Ireland travelled to the UK
to have abortions
that's almost nine a day and it's
estimated that 1,500 illegal abortion
pills are ordered online each year the
Catholic Church in Ireland has
encouraged its followers to vote no to
abortion but critics here say its moral
authority has weakened after a series of
child abuse scandals and this is a
nation that has been leaning more
liberal in the past few decades in 1995
they legalized divorce in 2015 they
legalized gay marriage if abortion is
legalized women will be allowed to
terminate within the first twelve weeks
of pregnancy
Kayla Jonathan Vigliotti reporting from
Dublin thank you